in this video we'll study about epilepsy
epilepsy is a disorder which occurs due
to one or more chronic conditions of the
body in which there occurs disturbed
nerve cell activity in the brain this
leads to recurrent seizures in the
person it occurs due to one or more
chronic conditions like the brain injury
after a road traffic accident which
leads to disturb nerve cell activity and
uncontrolled no activity in the brain it
is important to differentiate between
the words epilepsy and seizure epilepsy
is a condition which occurs due to
excessive and uncontrolled neuronal
activity in the brain this uncontrolled
neuronal activity can be generalized or
it can be localized to one area of the
brain for example it can be localized to
just the area of the brain which
perceives that touch sensations of the
body or it can be localized to the area
which controls the motor function of the
body it can also be localized to one of
the areas like the visual and the
auditory perception areas now the result
of the excessive neuronal discharge in
one of these areas is called a seizure
and the time of the seizure will depend
upon the area of the brain that is
affected now let's talk about the
mechanism of seizure development
normally there exists a balance between
the excitation and inhibition of neurons
in the central nervous system including
the brain and all the neuronal pathways
this is maintained by chemicals like
acetylcholine and gaba
seizures developed when a group of
neurons in the brain becomes hyper
excitable now this usually happens in
two phases the first phase is called the
initiation phase in which some neurons
do some reason become hyper excited and
start to have excessive neuronal
discharges one of the most important
reason is decreased sodium levels of the
body called hyponatremia the second
phase is called the propagation phase
now normally the neurons which have
neuronal discharges are surrounded by a
zone of inhibitory neurons called the
zone of hyper-polarization this zone of
hyper-polarization prevents the spread
of excessive neuronal discharges to
other parts of the brain but due to some
abnormality in the brain like decreased
sodium levels of the body the zone of
hyper-polarization gets depolarized and
the spread of neurons can occur to the
other parts of the brain so this is how
the seizure propagates to other parts of
the brain after it has been initiated in
one region of the brain one important
term to understand here is epileptic
Genesis in the mechanism of seizure
development we took the example of
decreased sodium levels in the body
called hyponatremia well initially event
for the seizure can be a more permanent
type of injury called brain injury due
to road traffic accidents in this type
of brain injury the neuronal networks
become chronically hyper excitable that
there is a permanent change in the
neuronal networks which results in
spontaneous seizures in the person this
process in which a normal neuronal
network is converted into a permanent
chronic hyper excitable one is called
epileptic Genesis now let's talk about
the various types and classification of
seizures and epilepsy seizures are
broadly defined into two categories the
generalized and the focal seizures the
generalized seizures usually start at
one place in the brain and then due to
widespread neuronal networks this spread
to whole of the cerebral cortex so the
main characteristic of generalized
seizures is their spread of the seizure
one of the main important structures
that helps in the spread is the corpus
callosum which connects Possley
hemispheres and due to this the seizure
spreads to the other hemisphere of the
brain
in comparison the focal seizures are
confined to one area of the brain where
they originate which is usually one
hemisphere or a small part of one
hemisphere
now let's talk about generalized
seizures in a bit detail generalized
seizures are of many types and one of
the most common type of generalized
seizures is the generalized tonic-clonic
seizures in generalized tonic-clonic
seizures there is widespread and
uncontrolled neuronal activity in whole
of the cerebral cortex and generalized
tonic-clonic seizures happen in almost
10% of the patients with epilepsy as I
mentioned generalized tonic-clonic
seizures involve all of the cerebral
cortex and there is excessive neuronal
discharge in the motor nerves through
the brain due to this excessive neuronal
discharge in the motor nerves the
muscles of the body get contracted
without any relaxation this is called
the tonic phase of the generalized
tonic-clonic seizure in which the
muscles remain totally contracted also
there is loss of consciousness in the
patient and Tony phase is characterized
by many other symptoms and one of them
is the if they'll cry which is a typical
sound produced by the tonic contractions
of the muscles of larynx and exploration
one of the characteristic of the tonic
phase is the impairment of the
respiratory drive which causes the
cyanosis in the patient there is also a
tonic contractions of the muscles of the
jaw due to which tongue bites can occur
in addition to the increased motor
activity in the nerves there is also
increased sympathetic discharge from
brain which causes increased heart rate
and blood pressure
the tonic phase usually lasts for 10 to
20 seconds and then it transforms into
the chronic phase
in the clonic phase the continuous
discharge from the drain gets
interrupted by small durations of
relaxation this occurs because
inhibitory mechanisms of the brain come
into play and try to control divide
spread neuronal activity due to this
there occur alternate muscle relaxations
and contractions which cause possum and
jerking and this is perceived as violent
shaking of muscles the chronic phase
usually lasts for only one minute and
then it transforms into the post octal
phase the postictal phase is
characterized by a confusion
unresponsiveness and muscular flaccidity
in the patient the patient usually
remains in the postictal phase for one
or two hours after which he gradually
transforms into the normal state
there are other types of generalized
seizures as well like the generalized
tonic and the generalized clonic
seizures these type of seizures are
characterized by symptoms of only the
tonic and chronic phase respectively
without transforming into another states
one another type of generalized seizure
is called the generalized absence
seizure this is very important as it is
the most common type of seizure in the
children and it is considered due to a
genetic abnormality in the children
generalized absence seizures are
characterized by sudden and brief loss
of consciousness in the patients without
loss of muscle tone these seizures
usually last only four seconds and there
is usually no postictal confusion other
type of generalized seizures include
atonic seizures and myoclonic seizures
now let's talk about the focal seizures
like we just discussed focal seizures
usually remain confined to a particular
area in the brain so the symptoms of the
focal seizures depend upon the site of
the brain that is involved and also the
spread of the seizure if the seizure
activity remains confined to the motor
area of the brain the symptoms that are
produced are usually the muscle jerking
in one area of the body
some patients also exhibit turning of
head to the one side if focal seizures
occur in the visual cortex of the brain
the symptoms are usually flashes of
light which are only perceived by the
patient and similarly if the focal
seizures occur in the auditory cortex of
the brain the patient perceives the
ringing sounds in the year and if the
seizure activity occurs in the sensory
area of the brain it is perceived as
sensations or Falls touched by the
patient focus seizures can also be
differentiated into two types that is
focal seizures without this cognitive
features and focal seizures with dis
cognitive features the dis cognitive
features mainly involve the impairment
of consciousness so in the first
category the patient usually does not
have any impairment of consciousness and
it is fully conscious even during the
seizure he is able to interact normally
with the surroundings this M of seizures
were previously classified as simple
partial seizures in the second type of
seizures that is where the
this cognitive features the patient
exhibits marked impairment of
consciousness but not loss of
consciousness the patient appears to be
awake but does not interact or answers
anyone's questions the same of seizures
were previously classified as complex
partial seizures now let's talk about
the etiology or the cause of seizures
and epilepsy you can easily remember all
the causes of epilepsy by remembering a
simple mnemonic vitamins T in this
mnemonic v stands for all the vascular
causes that are associated with the
blood supply of the brain these include
stroke bleeding and AV malformations
like Barry's aneurysm i stands for
infection and infections which mainly
cause epilepsy are the meningitis and
brain abscesses trauma is one of the
leading causes of epilepsy in both young
and adult patients Rho traffic accidents
and penetrating injuries of the brain
come under this section epilepsy can
also be a result of autoimmune diseases
like CNS vasculitis and systemically
lupus erythematosus
various metabolic disorders are a very
very common cause of epilepsy and
seizures
they include hypoglycemia hyponatremia
and many other metabolic disorders some
epilepsy conditions do not have any
cause or the cause is unknown that are
considered to be idiopathic epilepsies n
stands for neoplasms which includes all
the space occupying lesions of CNS and
brain from s you can remember all the
psychiatric disorders which lead to
epilepsy s and D is a very important
category that is drugs drugs are very
important cause of epilepsy and common
drugs which cause seizures
include alcohol phencyclidine and
cocaine so this was all about the
mechanism classification and etiology of
epilepsy in the next video in the series
we will discuss about the treatment and
diagnosis of epilepsy follow us on
Facebook for all the latest flash cards
and upcoming stuff if you want to
connect to me in a better way follow me
on instagram at lost in the north's
where i share my travel and landscape
photography thank you so much for
watching this video